The last rule says
He catches a cat when you meet her around the road
This section is the most personal and intimate door in the book
It has a lot about my daughter
My daughter was very sick when she was ...
When she was small
Especially when she was in her teenage years
She suffered a very difficult time
She had rheumatoid arthritis
When she was between 14 and 16
At first she destroyed her hip
It has to be replaced
She then destroyed her ankle in the other man
It had to be replaced
So she walked for about two years with two broken men
She had to take huge doses of narcotics
Making it barely conscious
She also had autoimmune disease at an advanced stage
Causing all other symptoms
Which was as bad as the deterioration of her joints
But more difficult than I can describe
This was very cruel and terrible, it was a test of our faith
There is almost no more explicit test
From a powerful illness affecting an innocent child
So this door was contemplating all this
What should we do in such a circumstance?
Because everyone will live in a similar situation
Somewhat, you know
You will face a sick person one day and you will face crises
So this is a practical guide to overcoming this kind of time
So, one of the things I would recommend doing when you are in trouble
Is to narrow your time frame
You know, when you can not think about next month
Or maybe you're in a position you can not even think about next week
Or perhaps tomorrow
Because you are at that moment in a situation where you can not see salvation
If this is the solution, it is to narrow your time frame
To be able to skip
If you do not know how you can survive until next week
If only think tomorrow
If you can not guarantee tomorrow, think about the next hour
If not the next hour if the next minute
You know, humans are very, very
Very very powerful
This shows when you face things ...
This appears when you face things
You can fight it and tolerate it more than I thought
You can pass without losing you
My daughter fully recovered
Almost as a result of her research
They have concluded the imbalance and have begun to take the necessary steps to fix it
Her recovery for me was a miracle I had never seen before
Overall, part of my talk about the cat
I began by talking about our dog who actually died
A year ago he is still alive in the book
You know, I tell you this because dog lovers love their dogs
If you like a cat they think you do not like dogs
And then they do not love you. That's why I pointed to it at the beginning of the door [laughing]
If you want to have a dog in the street, that's okay
You do not have to be angry and all that
If the idea is that you should notice
When you are in the midst of suffering
You should pay attention to the aesthetics of life
Unusual beauty
That's what made me enter the story of the cat
Where there was a cat living in the street opposite us
Ginger is called a Siamese cat
Cats are not really domesticated animals
Technically she is still said to be a predator, but she loves humans
No one but God knows why, but she loves them
And if Ginger was coming and hovering
Our dog sees her, but they were friends
She used to come and play on his back and Siegel (the dog) used to take care of her
It is the kind that lurches around you to make you feel like it
If she wanted to
If so, you should notice these few
Of small shiny jewels in the midst of darkness
When things are bad see and notice
To where you can see beauty
And where something is still going on
If you narrow your boundaries and begin to feel grateful for what you have
This helps you go on at some very difficult times
Which may end happily if you are lucky
But it may end in sorrow
And then, perhaps it may be tragic, but it is not hell at all
You know, you can do it. At worst, you can only keep it tragic instead of turning it into a hell
There is a huge difference between tragedy and hell
There is nothing worse in attending a funeral
Of seeing people quarreling
Death is bad enough, but you can make it worse and make it unbearable
Perhaps, this is what I concluded by my book,
The idea that we were not trying to make things bad
Worse than it originally was
Perhaps we have to reconcile these terrible things with us so we can live
Perhaps we can make the world a better place
This is what we are supposed to do, and what we can do
Because we have nothing better to do!
This is what the book is about
This was the end of the twelve rules of life
[clap]